think I'm like cool give that one
[Music]
yeah stick that finger up my cool well
what's this over here
yes
BAM what's up [ __ ] here from a
different site
we can't smoke in this we got blowing
smoke out with you understand me listo
recovering from the [ __ ] El Cid
liquid we gave me our name Jesus Christ
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
you uncle Joey here Lisa at still
recovering from the [ __ ] said and
[ __ ] you know it's a beautiful [ __ ]
day to be alive we're smoking with your
token we're doing everything you
understand me can we make an invention
[Music]
good evening what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here I like to
put a Puerto Rican stamp together
listen Pollock some Puerto Ricans are
known for [ __ ] inventing their own
type of [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I'm saying
well you can't take humans do we get the
[ __ ] Cubans do it what's happening
you're bad [ __ ] uncle Joey here
giving you love on a Wednesday August
17th
the office was moving outside I'm sorry
a little [ __ ] assassin and we
got a little [ __ ] ghost
oh gee mmm the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with here
yeah I don't even know if our guest is
gonna show there you know yeah [ __ ] it
no name I don't know what's going on no
more people I have no idea I'm just
trying to [ __ ] put things together
and this is all I get mental abuse bells
going off I hate everything you don't
say
that's what these people leave their way
to the dance my friend
give the bag of stars leak you guys
thought we forgot about the rest the
purpose we don't know we don't do red
stars red stars are for people in
training you understand we're opening up
with a thousand today just like that one
two three four and that one on the floor
that's even better I told them no more
animals no more nothing but [ __ ] that we
got a hold back and it's gotta go you
know I'm saying for right is I got two
left three
hey listen you wanna play games go hang
out with somebody else go hang out with
some other comics let's don't have there
nothing there nothing they got you like
Jarrod had America like Cosby had
America that's half they got you your
dumb [ __ ] right here here's one edge
you want to get down you wanna know what
the latest information is on reefer you
want to talk about the [ __ ] acid from
the Mars this is where the [ __ ] it ends
right here [ __ ] uncle Joey mmm
600 milligrams two more to go like
nothing who the [ __ ] you know that opens
up with a thousand at three o'clock in
the afternoon
you don't know many people will do that
[ __ ] do you uncle Joey's the one
throwing he's dying for your [ __ ] send
you understand me trying the product
where's that chocolate mushroom right
over here show these [ __ ] people with
we got chocolate-covered mushrooms you
understand me
made with love up in [ __ ] Billings
Montana look at this thing
do people sitting at home going Joey how
do you do it look at this oh Jesus
Christ oh Jesus
it smells like feet ass
and ringworm put together but it's good
it does the [ __ ] trick understand me
you want to see the devil you got
evening work that's it
plaintiff [ __ ] simple you know I love
you people v8 team get off now I don't
want no drama 18 and over only fumble
Joey's [ __ ] periscopes I'm getting
calls from moms and dads and kids at 10
they want to [ __ ] do stars of death I
can't have it I can't have it on my
clock [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
anymore you understand me with just a
[ __ ] ship full of fools navigate me
what you say you want to buy at least
believe the stars he still has one more
[ __ ] start I could 810 stars nothing
fine he's eating them like they're
cooking you see what I got to deal with
what the [ __ ] the other night he got
[ __ ] [ __ ] up he kept telling me am
I in the hospital that's when you know
you [ __ ] up when you think you're in
the hospital
one lady just Texas we're back getting
our head together here we think about
those chocolate mushrooms huh what do
you think you think no [ __ ] here
wasting time you think we're here you
know playing [ __ ] guns and robbers
and [ __ ] well [ __ ] with tearing it up in
Cali you don't want to come visit us
that's your did you know you want to go
to all these exotic locales no we want
to go here there yeah
you ain't gonna know it you know why cuz
nobody brings it like uncle Joey no more
that's just a feel of random 60 70
nobody brings it when I can't go Joey no
more you take a chance Columbus did
[ __ ] is sitting there waiting for
what you're waiting for a bus that you
don't want to get on and you don't want
it to [ __ ] come cuz you're sitting
there like I don't know what I'm gonna
do it my life well it all starts with a
bong it a bomb it will change you it'll
put in perspective then maybe catch in
jiu-jitsu class write some goals
suddenly an email whatever you need to
[ __ ] do we're here for you you
understand me
bomb hit swords loot chucks whatever you
need we got will one to [ __ ] stop
shopping here for the menthol you
understand me leave really wants to buy
this chocolate mushroom I want to hold
on to it till Halloween leave my goal no
Halloween
let's eat those chocolate [ __ ] stars
right now we thankfully a little bite
[ __ ] Halloween I don't trick-or-treat
near to you young same
we ain't got little trick-or-treaters
here [ __ ] this is straight-up
you know there's like two pucks mom
she's in Cuba somewhere I gotta go down
to Cuba now I'll pick her up
I need this aggravation of my life with
a small half of Milken you believe that
[ __ ] I paying for two pucks mom is done
it who wants to buy the chocolate what
do you think should we oh yeah this is
good this is your B you think your
sister could be a senior system could
recover Lee look e you can even see the
you could see the like what do you got
over there a lot of facts what do you
got like a fossil you can see the fossil
of a mushroom right in the middle there
look at it it's pure discussed but yummy
for your tummy you understand me a lot
of people never have the chance to eat
chocolate covered mushrooms and we got
them right here today on the church what
are you getting all about Lee what the
[ __ ] you giggling about you know not
many people have the chance and we're
putting it together here with that you
know we got it together here somebody
actually in Billings Montana said Joey
we want you to see the [ __ ] devil the
way we see him and billions here
shoveling snow riding the horse you busy
devil riding the horse it's [ __ ] up
but it happens we got no music on till a
couple of minutes we're just warming it
up here trying to get this whole [ __ ]
party started you know it's hot
jiu-jitsu was tremendous my meeting was
tremendous you know I can't ask for
nothing more if you came out the [ __ ]
the black horse last night we had a nice
time it was a small crowd but powerful
we'll be there again next Tuesday trying
out [ __ ] and working it out [ __ ]
you understand me do you know why
because we love you and it's [ __ ]
Wednesday that's why this is it this is
it tomorrow's Thursday then you got
Friday then you know what is UFC 202
either you're gonna make money are you
gonna go home cry that's it it's that
simple Pelham
that's all you can be see what happened
to the press before the Diaz brothers
came in in the back and they were
throwing stuff in Encarna guns and start
throwing like the soda bottles in the
water bottle did the cancel the press
pound will they throw stuff at the Diaz
brothers and then Conor McGregor like
McGregor was on the stage and the Diaz
brothers in their whole camp keep
without the door just like an atom
tremendous it's all the mental this
hitter it's gonna be a mental [ __ ]
ward so we go down the [ __ ] at the
hand you know Porto Ricans with knives
white dudes with stars whatever the [ __ ]
you need we got you're following
Mexicans with boots and that's it we're
here we're queer we're gonna get this
party started
we're gonna get this podcast started
about 15 [ __ ] minutes so get ready
around [ __ ] cause uncle Joey's
coming straight ahead for you I don't
even know what that means anymore
I really don't I really don't I don't
like my daughter says I dog daddy I dog
[Music]